Two important TLS concepts are the TLS
sessions and the TLS connection.
A TLS session is an association
between a client and
a server that is created
by the Handshake Protocol.
It defines a set of
cryptographic parameters
that are used by a set of
connections within the session.
So that we can avoid repeated
expensive negotiation of new
security parameters for
each new connection.
A TLS connection is a transport layer
relationship between a client and
a server.
For example, a TLS connection can be
an email connection between a client and
a server, or
it can be a set of such connections.
A TLS connection is transient, for
example if the client terminates
the email connection,
the TLS connection may terminate.
Whereas TLS session is much
longer term because it is created
by a Handshake Protocol rather than a a
transport layer service such as email,
each TLS connection is
part of a TLS session.
Therefore, negotiation of
new security parameters for
each connection can be avoided.